il était 1038 les compagnons de la
libération
1038 réunis pour l'éternité et pas un de
plus à avoir été adoubé par le général
de gaulle pour avoir combattu avec lui
dès le début deux d'entre eux acceptent
ici aux invalides de témoigner hubert
germain et fred moore leur destin ce sel
dès l'armistice le 17 juin 1940
le 17
j'ai eu tout le discours du maréchal
pétain
c'est le coeur serré le jeu vous dites
aujourd'hui ils posent effet le gros bas
vous êtes dit quoi quand on a entendu
sans me dis mais c'est un [ __ ] mon
premier a ignoré disque ans a été un peu
grossier venir a été géré mais en une
gouvernement français
engagé dans les forces françaises libres
ils vont faire les mêmes campagnes
1941 la syrie 1942 la libye 1943 n'est
tunisie pour empêcher les allemands
d'occuper le moyen-orient
fred moore présente ses souvenirs de
campagne
il n'a rien oublié de ses combats
pas le moindre détail
la cme a blindé perdu on a été hachée ce
lp un coup de canon direct de 75 mais il
avait et robin heureusement pour nous il
a visé c'est tombé au niveau sous la
caisse
alors moi j'ai été soulevée par le
souffle de l'obuts quand il est passé je
suis tombé sur les fesses et ses bons
déshonneur parce que j'ai suis tombé
dans les cactus
alors là j'aime autant vous dire que
j'en ai eu pour moi en tunisie niang
hospitalisé aux invalides hubert germain
ne s'encombre lui d'aucun objet ni
photos ni documents pour nous confier
son sentiment je vous met tout de suite
à l'aise les décorations en soit on s'en
fout
c'est pas ça qui est un an et avec les
façons de les voir des décorations pour
sur ceux qui sont là elles y voient une
consécration
certains c'est une erreur ça veut dire
où s'arrête et puis comme les
décorations sous verre la chambre à
coucher ont dit tu vois glauben j'étais
un héros mais si vous voulez considéré
que l'éducation qui nous sont attribués
c'est un moment de mise au point
où dans l'ombre une voix vous dit
tu as bien joué jusqu'ici on te demande
davantage
les compagnons de la libération ont tous
reçu cette simple croix de bronze
présenté ici face et revers aujourd'hui
ne sont plus que 15 les derniers à
pouvoir encore porter l'emblème des
premiers résistants parmi eux hubert
germain et fred moore présent demain
matin pour la commémoration de l'appel
du 18 juin
[Musique]